all right we are in the final push now
to donate to our great
school supply drive so even though we've
learned that kids are going to be
distance learning they still need those
basic essentials for their
at-home classrooms so let's check in
with ted who's at a local smiths with
more on our last minute
drive hi ted
hey denise and before i get to anything
i just ran into your dad
we gave a good elbow bump and he wanted
to say hi arturo was here
he bought he's bringing some ice cream
home to let you know
what the odds of that right all right so
yeah
of course the most important thing of
course the reason why we're here is
because we want to help those kids
in clark county okay and one of the
reasons we're doing this too
is because this school supply drive the
great school supply drive will benefit
shade trees so we want to bring in linda
perez the ceo of shade tree
to explain the correlation between not
only school supplies but but shade tree
tell us what it is
yeah absolutely first of all thank you
channel 8 for covering this heartwarming
story and
smith's for doing this for us it is
definitely a necessity at the shade tree
right now
the shae tree is an emergency shelter
and we house women and children
in crisis and because of our partnership
with noah's animal house
we're able to house pets as well which
is really important
right now with the world the way it is
school is still a priority we don't know
what's going to happen with the children
with
the situation right now so we have to
have school for the children that we
have in the shelter right now
if it was their choice they would choose
not to be at the shade tree
but we have to create a supportive
learning environment for them
so in our children's activities center
they will have that environment where
they'll have a learning instructor
and all of these school supplies that
everyone has gathered and donated for us
is extremely important for the older
kids we are going to
school them in our cox technology center
where there's computers
where we'll have a learning instructor
as well to help them through this
process as well
but all of these beautiful school
supplies are definitely needed and we're
so grateful at the shade tree
you get me choked up every time all the
time and thank you so much
thank you and you did a great job thank
you so much for doing that you heard it
linda and shade tree just doing a
fantastic job to help these kids out all
right
at their facilities so they need these
school supplies so please
go to your local smiths find those great
school supplied boxes like you see here
and please make the donation i mean pens
and pads anything crayons
scissors they're fairly cheap all right
let's get to our